dans son cartable abel n'oublie pas de
mettre ses cahiers et avant de partir
son casque de vélo
abel pourquoi tu mets un casque pour
aller à l'école pour la sécurité car
pour rouler en centre ville
il vaut mieux bien se protéger mais abel
et son père ne pédalent rend pas tout
seul ils rejoignent le départ de la
ligne 1 du vélobus de mâcon rappelle
quelques règles de sécurité très
importantes
la première garder les distances de
sécurité les pilotes de ligne s'assure
que les consignes de sécurité sont bien
intégrés les parents ont reçu une charte
avec les 10 règles d'or à faire
respecter aux enfants et c'est parti
pour 25 minutes de trajet qu'il vente ou
qu'il pleuve tous les parents qui sont
réticents dès qu'il ya un petit peu de
pluie
dès qu'il ya un petit peu de fraîcheur
un peu de 3 alors qu'il faudrait pas et
c'est justement ces clichés là qu'on
voudrait casser avec l'association
d'expliquer aux parents que c'est pas
parce qu'il pleut qu'on peut pas
circuler à vélo sans picador les
accompagnateurs souvent des parents
veillent à bien encadrer les enfants
et comme les bus un premier arrêt est
effectué pour récupérer nos âmes vers
sauf que c'est super pour les enfants
franchement il sent groupe donc à
l'esprit d'équipé puis vont à l'école au
moins en vélo c'est génial le trajet
prévoit trois arrêts si des parents ont
inscrit leurs enfants car il faut rouler
d'un bon train et respecter les horaires
prévus pour ne pas manquer lors du début
des cours
ça fait d'histoire pour le matin et ça
réveille vachement on ne pollue pas la
planète et je retrouve mes copains et
pour faire du vélo tous ensemble dans
les années 70 pour cent des français
utilisent et le vélo aujourd'hui on est
moins de 3%
donc il faut que les petits français les
jeunes générations retrouve ce goût de
l'effort
il communique aux grands cette
expérimentation du vélobus est menée
avec une école du centre ville
l'association espère pouvoir à terme
étendre l'action à toutes les autres
écoles